[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installments of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing tamira of erised
and everyone's favorite potions
professor severus snape
snape is the subject of much controversy
in the harry potter universe
fighting for both good and evil forces
at one point or another
he's such a dynamic character and i
think that's why he's a good subject for
the question
what would snape see in the mirror of
erised in order to properly answer that
question
we need to take a look at his past snape
was born on january 9th
1960 to a muggle father tobias snape
and which mother eileen prince and grew
up in the muggle
town of spinus end spinner's end was in
close proximity to cokeworth
another small muggle town where the
evans family lived
because of the close proximity of the
two villages it was only a matter of
time before snape would meet lily evans
a girl that he would later become deeply
infatuated with
after meeting the two would go on to
spend a considerable amount of time
together
and in 1971 the pair began attending
school at hogwarts
the beginning of snape's tragedy was in
that same year when they were sorted
into different houses
snape was sorted into slytherin and lily
into gryffindor
and though that didn't mean that they
were unable to see each other it did
mean they spent a bit more time apart
it also didn't help that slithering and
gryffindor were rival houses
also sorted into gryffindor were the
marauders sirius black
remus lupin peter pettigrew and of
course james potter
james potter was a talented student but
also a huge bully
he spent a lot of his time ridiculing
and pestering snape who grew to hate him
with a passion
snape's incessant bullying at the hands
of james and the marauders
led to his introduction to the dark arts
at a very young age
snape's introduction to the dark arts
was never good for anyone
particularly because he was an extremely
talented young wizard his future was
quite promising
and while learning his primary course
material at hogwarts would even scribble
in his notebook and
invent curses charms and potions snape
even produced his own version of the
potion's class textbook
under the alias the half bud prince
however lily
who snape remained friends with didn't
like the path that he was going down
or the people that he was spending his
time with thought we were supposed to be
friends
snape was saying best friends we are sev
but i don't like some of the people
you're hanging around with i'm sorry but
i detest avery and mossaba
malzah what do you see in him sev he's
creepy
do you know what he tried to do to marry
mcdonald the other day lily had reached
a pillar and leaned against it
looking up into the thin sallow face
that was nothing said snape
it was a laugh that's all it was dark
magic and if you think that's funny
and it was snape's pursuit of darkness
that further distanced him from lily
at that point in time he was intent on
achieving power he had discovered the
dark arts something that he was
particularly good at
and the sky was the limit why would he
give it up by continuing along this path
snape would eventually become a fully
fledged death eater serving lord
voldemort himself
he may have surrounded himself with the
wrong types of people but these people
praised his magical ability
snape didn't join the death eaters
because he was inherently evil
he joined him because he was unsure of
his place in the world all he knew was
these people accepted him for who he was
and no one else did however in the year
sible trolloni predicted the fabled
prophecy a prophecy that would change
everything and turn snape's world upside
down
the one with the power to vanquish the
dark lord approaches born to those who
have thriced to fight him
born as the seventh month dies and the
dark lord will mark him as his equal
but he will have power the dark lord
knows not and either must die at the
hands of the other
for neither can live while the other
survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord
will be born as the seventh month dies
severus snape who was a death eater at
the time
quickly found out about the prophecy as
he was infatuated with lily
harry's mother he knew almost
immediately that he would need to act
he knew that he would have to do
something but how could he ensure that
lily potter stays safe
with nowhere else to go snape turned his
enemy at the time
albus dumbledore well severus what
message does lord voldemort have for me
nope no message i'm here on my own
account snape was ringing his hands
he looked a little mad with his
straggling black hair flying around him
i i come with a warning no a request
please what request could a death eater
make of me
the the prophecy the prediction trelawny
ah yes sir dumbledore how much should
you relate to lord voldemort
everything everything i heard said snape
that is why
it is for that reason he thinks it means
lily evans
the prophecy did not refer to a woman
said dumbledore it spoke of a boy
born at the end of july you know what i
mean he thinks it means her son
he's going to hunt her down kill them
all if she means so much to you
said dumbledore surely lord voldemort
will spare her
could you not ask for mercy for the
mother in exchange for the sun
i have i have asked him you disgust me
said dumbledore and harry had never
heard so much contempt in his voice
snape seemed to shrink a little you do
not care then about the deaths of her
husband and child
they can die as long as you have what
you want snape said nothing
but millie looked up at dumbledore snape
was a desperate man
and at this point in time would have
done anything to protect the woman he
loved
lily evans snape told dumbledore that he
would do anything
to ensure that lilly was protected and
this was a testament to snape's devotion
to lily
he dropped his deathly to status in a
life that he had built for himself in an
instant
when he found out that lilly was in
danger however all of this ended up
being in vain
as on october 31 1981 voldemort found
the potter residence
traveling there with one goal kill the
boy when he entered their home he
quickly ended the life of james potter
and then started making his way towards
lily and baby harry
when voldemort approached lily he asked
her to step aside
and let him have harry he said that if
she did so he would spare her life
but obviously lily's only goal was to
protect her son
and she was subsequently murdered by
voldemort's evada cadaver
when voldemort turned his wand on harry
his curse rebounded back at him the
result of lilly's sacrificial protection
it marked the end of voldemort for a
time but also the end of lily potter
the mirror of erised is a magical mirror
that shows us the deepest most desperate
desires
of our hearts this is reflected in the
mirror's name no pun intended
as error said flipped around reads as
desire
the mirror itself was made sometime
before the end of the 19th century
and is located in the room of
requirement in hogwarts
in the films we see very few characters
actually stand in front of the mirror
and i think this is a good thing because
it allows us to speculate
with the tragic life that snape had
lived i think there are a few things
that he would have seen
had he looked into the mirror i think
that it goes without saying that
whatever snape saw would be somehow
related
to lily evans however what i think we
can theorize on is the sage of his life
that he would see himself
and possibly lily i think the earliest
possible event that snape would see in
the mirror would be the hogwarts sorting
ceremony
in the year 1971 the year that him and
lily were sorted
this was a pivotal moment in both of
their lives as they put stress on their
friendship
they were sorted into different houses
rival houses at that
and this may have been the defining
moment that put them on completely
different paths
i think that in this scenario snape
would have seen himself in lilly
being sorted into the same house
slytherin or gryffindor
i don't think it would have mattered as
long as he was with lily
this would have meant their paths never
diverged quite so much
and could have resulted in a very
different future for them both my second
theory is that snape would have seen
himself and lily
together in fifth year fifth year was
important because it was the year that
snape really secured his path of
darkness
it was also the year that he caught lily
potter and mud blood
i never meant to call you in my blood it
just slipped out
it's too late i've made excuses for you
for years none of my friends can
understand why i even talk to you
you and your precious little death eater
friends you've chosen your way
i've chosen mine lily never understood
why snape hung out with the would-be
death eaters she didn't like them
and it only distanced the pair in an
interview rowling was actually asked why
snape didn't excuse himself from their
company
sooner for lily's sake she responded
well
that is snape's tragedy given his time
over again he would not have become a
death eater but like many insecure
vulnerable people like wormtail he
craved membership of something big and
powerful
something impressive he wanted lily and
he wanted multiple two
he never really understood lilly's
aversion he was so blinded by his
attraction to the dark side
he thought she would find him impressive
if he became a real death eater
so to answer the question i think that
snape would have seen himself and lily
in fifth year
the pair would be closer than ever and
snape would have never followed the dark
path
that he eventually let himself down he
would have never called lily potter in
mudblood
and a future with lily would have still
been possible the two would be lying on
the grass
looking up the clouds smiling holding
hands
and that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it what do
you guys think snape would have seen in
the mirror of erised
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard
you